Kira I want you to do me a favor
okay okay I want you to keep everyone
away from the
windows I Love A Space Adventure
especially from inside a space station
ISS is about three Americans three
Russians who Coexist on the
International Space Station they end up
being a family it's kind of how it works
up there a World War unfolds on Earth
both governments reach out to their
respective astronauts ask them to take
control of the station by any means
necessary and things go dark pretty
quickly what do you suggest we do
now Kira Foster is a young and upand
cominging science engineer the audience
gets to know the ISS through Kira's eyes
we don't talk politics here we one it's
really cool to be sharing screen with
Ariana de obviously multifaceted and
talented she's just coming off of like
Westside Story Spielberg K's function is
to take in each person and let let the
audience make their decisions around
it when I first thought of how this was
going to work doing zero gravity and
every scene the cage became this mobile
device that we can hang all our cast
members at once and do what the zero
gravity needs to look like including the
action
scenes I always like movies that take
heightened and extreme ideas and then
try to find a way to make them feel
relatable it's a really interesting take
on actual reality it's different from a
lot of space movies the audience go on
the ride with us I like feeling like
it's here and now and that this is
actually something that could be
happening up there it's a story about
survival it's a story about human
instincts it's a story about
[Music]
Mankind